hallöchen liebe freunde euro freddy wir
nehmen fifa auf nach dem letzten putt
opening hab ich mir gedacht
mit freddy auf bisschen spielen
und ja was ihr seht schon vier spiele
gemacht sieg niederlage unentschieden
niederlage die beiden niederlagen kamen
nicht also sie kamen wegen abbruch und
zwar guckt euch das mal an da zum
beispiel da sieht man jetzt die eine
niederlage gegen olympia fc 2 5 verloren
angeblich das war das ergebnis nach 30
minuten also das war total komisch das
war mann hat gewonnen und hat trotzdem
abzug bekommen oder so das war einfach
noch richtig komisch
allgemein so die letzte zeit weil mir
gedacht ich hier wieder ein wenig so
passt das eigentlich erst mal ich muss
schauen wie das wird latenz passt läuft
werde der druck am anfang nicht das ist
cook jetzt schon
müssen wir schauen wie das wird
italiener fast italiener ist gar nicht
installieren doch alle in italien nur
auf die länder geguckt aber ich habe mit
meinem team aufgebaut
alles noch ländern nein ich hasse regen
können direkt abbrechen
ich hasse das die spieler laufen oft
einfach nicht zum ball und dieser elgato
die reagiert zu spät musste man den
unterschied an du musst gleich mal mit
der karte spielen während wie
angeschlossen ist die ganzen reaktion
die kommen aber erst ein bisschen später
das total doof ich muss sich quasi immer
so ein bisschen vor plan
rolf doch alter
nein nein ich muss man hier als liegt
stimmt mitteldrittel du redest neben die
mikro herde mussten ja zum mikro werde
weg wenn man etwas sagen du kannst ein
bisschen kommentieren
wegen dieser will einfach zu schön
das ist einfach die sache weniger klar
wegen dieser blöden elgato das letzte
super pass nein
morand was an mvg hat das verstellt dass
ein schlechtes stellungsspiel
stellungsspiel gott und dafür welches
bestraft
er wurde ohne linie um den schiri haben
es nicht gesehen borger diese pässe ich
könnte kotzen grad schon ist auch so
ich glaube er kommt der geht ins aus
nein hey junge hatte dass ich ziehe man
die mitte machten ein flip das mobiliar
kreativ
reagiert das wollte ich wiederum auch
nicht
naja weil spanien spielt ja ich würde
gern ich glaube allerdings wer besser
nicht erwartet sondern hd pvr gag hat
nochmal das kannst du besser das kannst
du besser verstanden du das wetter
was gegner in der nähe
ich habe eine roulette gemacht in 1
roulette ist nicht das logo gibt
da gebe ich dann wieder den ring alter
ich habe eigentlich wieder umbauen
jetzt konnte
eltern muss ich mich ein bisschen
nein einfach umhaut ja das sind sie
diese abwehr spieler die oft von vorn
bis hinten inszeniert und das ist jetzt
ein problem weil er verliert den ball
und hat jetzt hinten keinen fall genau
jetzt hat er nämlich hinten kein
verteidiger siehst du da oben da bin ich
jetzt für mich räume und das war nicht
alles geplant und durch diese chance
hier haben kann
junge dieser scheiß regen einfach ist
einfach so will ich echt zu gern die
leute sehen so die diese spiele ein paar
leuten jetzt total träge spielen ohne
krieg meine chancen werden so schlecht
das wissen auch alle bei youtube hier in
dem ein spiel dadurch 30 torschuss ab
wie ist da noch und trotzdem verloren
diese leute die tricks machen und die
nichts bringen
ich hasse dieses elgato ding ist das
reagiert zu spät
am besten ich finde einfach mal mit dem
iphone den bildschirm
jetzt jedoch durch da ich wollte zudem
nach oben spielen
nein dieses geld also den ich könnt
könnt der schreddern und wer überhaupt
gekauft
denn handy hartings motto soll da jetzt
er wieder mit verteidiger
das mache ich nicht
so müsse jetzt definitiv wieder hier
drauf gehen freunde nicht dass die
entscheidung löste auch bei den
brasilianern das sind einfach keine
schnellen leute dabei außer der ddr ist
ein bisschen schnell
linksaußen war dass das coole ist nach
gewissen zeit kennt man so die taktiken
von den gegnern wenn man so ein bisschen
gespielt
ein tor
das einfach ja ich hab's doch selber
nicht spiele erinnern aber jetzt sind es
kann doch nicht sein
es ist ja nur ein spiel und ich meinte
die rauchig soll
egal ob ich gewinne oder nicht aber
hauptsache live kommentieren und mit
spaß an der sache dabei sein und
vielleicht ja das liegt ja dieses
hundertprozentig da könnte ich stimme
kurz ein bisschen was um
ein paar gute bälle dann packe ich noch
einfacher bildung verteidigung für ein
spieler der bisher zwei ganz gut war
aber der ist nicht der schnellste und
braucht schnelle spieler vom wunderlich
du gehst raus nochmal alter gar nicht
laut amano
chillig lebenswichtige neue leute kommen
ab geht's
die angriffe zu stellen ja
die junge der die haben einfach immer
aus davor
da steckt durch scheiße den er geht rein
ich hätte es gab jedoch jetzt mal zum
ball ja junge längst hinten
wie schafft es der red sich immer da
durchzuwurschteln guckt da ist zum
beispiel ein spiel einfach nicht im
alltag überall rum
ich spiele ich mich direkt nach vorne
oben ist mir viel zu viel frei
das war zu
die sich an der freddy 2 0 führung ist
immer sicher immer ja klar dass man die
story erzählen vom letzten mal durch den
dienst natürlich schöner pass
im spiel selber schuld was da eigentlich
ja auch durch meter schießen noch
verloren rechnet damit dass luca
innerhalb von fünf minuten zwei tore
es ist einfach super flanke
ein pass
junge
ja ich muss jetzt möglichst lange
irgendwie den ball ja jung die psp titel
pussy schlüssel so einfach so nach vorne
es scheiße
kommerz ihr doppel ja kein absetzen wenn
die tonne schnell der macht den naja
muss eine menge von grone
absatz jedoch nicht
wo er den ball berührt die hoch gegen
der denn bitte ein fünfter der orgatec
pass auf letzten fünf minuten
ich kriege noch ein tor das ist einfach
der körper die brasilianer haben einfach
kein körper ich bin einfach ein anderes
haben die nicht
war kein abseits weil er da unten auf
stand carlos alberto zum jubel
der vogel sei schön mal wieder ein spiel
von mir übrigens kam mit solange kein
fieber mehr weil weil ich habe zwar
sachen aufgenommen aber ich habe das mal
mit dieser elgato mikrofon funktion
getestet
da war das also total rebellischen sich
deswegen aber stand jetzt mit einer
fliege macht das doch schon deutlich
besser kommen wird es ein klarer sieg
die klare nein
man lerne - geld und gott was taste mit
der flanke
so weiter geht's
nein ich würde jetzt ich würde
hundertprozentig noch ein tor machen
aber er vergab jakub naja freunde 30 ist
ganz gut mit meister eigentlich ganz gut
schreibt man die kommentare ob wir das
nächste spiel machen sollen ich gegen
freddy zwar nicht ultimate team aber so
ich sag mal ich gegen freddy einfach
sondern nicht dass dann so das video
nicht einfach da seht ihr viele tore
kontroverses jayjay fabrik us oder
fabrik us agent wieso hab apo münzen
bekommt vielleicht haben auch noch mal
verkaufte kann ja auch sein
gucken compact opening machen von einem
palin hintendran packen so vielleicht
gut mein leben freuen uns war es wie
immer bewährt nicht vergessen und die
nächste folge wird dann frederik basis
konkreter